there were some rumors that went around
after our last podcast episode
that the reason that I have not seen
Julie was because she doesn't want to
see me
um and that is just untrue Lindsey
Chrisley setting the record straight on
why she hasn't visited her stepmom Julie
in prison if you want to speak and for
whatever to be heard or believed then
you have to be accepting of the fact
that the other side is going to have
something to say too last month the
rumor started spreading after the
reality star said this on her Southern
tea podcast this person said I was
wondering if we could get a Julie update
and as far as I know she's doing well I
have not been to Lexington to visit her
yet so it was assumed Julie didn't want
Lindsay visiting but according to
Lindsay that's far from the truth and
she has her grandma to back her up I was
waiting in line myself because she put
me on the list she thought I'd be right
away because you know I'm the next thing
to her mother she put me on the list too
yeah and so they said well
mother-in-laws are not blood so you have
to wait three months Todd Chrisley's mom
Nanny Faye explaining the difficult
process it takes to visit Julie in
Kentucky where she's serving a
seven-year prison sentence for tax fraud
I've only got to see her three times so
it was almost two months before I ever
got to see her because of the way they
carry on their list they take their own
time so it's a process everything in
life now is a process so don't believe
anything you hear everything happens for
a reason and then the timing that it's
supposed to Lindsay's in contact with
both Julie and her dad who's serving his
12-year sentence in Florida she says
it's difficult but they make it work
finally have been able to communicate
over
their form of email for the first time
but also her email is very delayed and
dads is very different you can send him
an email
and you will hear back within maybe two
hours yeah response so it's it's been a
very and he doesn't get his backed up
days later
a very very different process I believe
that everything that happens
God already knows it's going to happen
and God he knows how you're going to get
through it
[Music]
foreign